-Here's what people
are talking about.
I saw that it snowed
at the White House today,
and temperatures
are below freezing.
I guess that's why Trump
spent the whole day
with his tongue
stuck to the flag pole.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"They triple dog dared me.
God bless the United States."
[ Laughter ]
This morning,
Trump visited the FBI.
Yep, he walked in,
saw his photo on the wall,
and was like, "Isn't that nice?
I'm the most wanted."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"No big deal."
This is very interesting.
Trump was the first president
to speak at the FBI graduation
since Richard Nixon.
So I guess
there's one more thing
Trump and Nixon
will have in common.
Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They're both --
They're both presidents.
This is pretty big.
Yesterday, Trump spoke on
the phone with Vladimir Putin.
Guess Putin heard all the drama
about Omarosa
and said, "I want every detail."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Dish that dirt, girl."
[ Laughter ]
This is nice.
The Trumps' official Christmas
portrait just came out.
Take a look at this.
There you are. Yeah.
That's Donald and Melania
surrounded by all the people
who still work
at the White House.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You guys see this?
Trump nominated a guy
named Matthew Petersen.
Did you see this?
He nominated a guy
named Matthew Petersen
for district judge,
and a lot of people are saying
that he's kind of unqualified.
I say let's give him a chance.
Let's see how he did
at his confirmation hearing.
-Have you ever tried
a jury trial?
-I have not.
-Civil?
-No.
-Criminal?
-Bench?
-No.
-State or federal court?
-I have not.
-Have you ever tried -- taken
a -- a deposition by yourself?
-Uh, I believe no.
-Have you ever argued a motion
in state court?
-I have not.
-Have you ever argued a motion
in federal court?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-"Have you ever watched
an episode of 'People's Court'?"
"No."
-"You ever been
on a basketball court?"
"No, I haven't."
"You ever eaten
at a food court?"
"No, I haven't."
-"Have you ever done anything
ever in your whole lifetime?"
-"I have not."
"Sounds good to me.
I think you're great."
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
Fantastic.
You guys, I saw that a statue
of soccer superstar
Diego Maradona
was just unveiled,
and some people don't think
it looks like him.
No.
See for yourself.
This is Maradona in his prime.
Now here's the statue.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people have spoken out
about the statue,
including Maradona himself.
He said...
Then his new statue
spoke up and said...
Then Maradona said...
Then the old statue
of Cristiano Ronaldo said...
[ Laughter ]
Then this old plaque
of Elvis Presley
showed up and said...
And finally, this wax figure
of Zac Efron said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's amazing.
They all said that.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
Come on.
-Well, it is the end of another
crazy week, and since --
[ Laughs ]
-Ermahgerd.
-It's old, but it works.
Since there's too much
to talk about,
instead of giving you
a full week in review,
we decided to put together
a little montage
that just focuses on
the keywords used this week
in something called
"This Week in Words."
Check it out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Breaking news.
-Doug Jones.
-Has won.
-The Alabama race.
-Is finally
-Done.
-The Republican lost.
-They're sending...
-Him back.
-Hit the road.
-Jack.
-Don't you...
-Come back.
-No more.
-Roy Moore.
-No Moore.
-Change.
-In the Senate.
-Conservative.
-Fears.
-The state's first Democrat
in 25 years.
-The poll shows the president's
approval rating sinking.
-But in...
-His mind.
-I beat Abraham Lincoln.
-Omarosa fired.
-Kicked to the street.
-Trump offered his goodbye
in a tweet.
-A day in the life.
-I'll just tell you folks.
-Eight hours of TV.
12 Diet Cokes.
-Net neutrality is...
-Reduced to...
-Nothing.
-"Jeopardy!" contestant
loves pushing a button.
-Media mergers.
-Still in talks.
-Disney and 21st Century Fox
are close to reaching a deal
that could be...
-Something unreal.
-They can...
-Finally...
-Combine.
-Other movies.
-To equal.
-Snow White and the...
-Planet.
-Of the Jed--
-Die hard with a...
-Big Hero 6.
-The sqeakquel.
-We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!